bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 11 décembre premier bilan
d'une enquête de dépistage de
l'encéphalopathie spongiforme bovine usb
pour les catégories étudiées on a relevé
un taux de deux bêtes malades pour mille
a minima à l'arraché mais un accord
quand même annoncé avant l'aube ce matin
à nice entre les 15 et à l'union
européenne ouvrant la voie à un
élargissement vers les pays de l'est
jean tiberi de plus en plus seul au
conseil de paris une trentaine d'adjoint
fidèles à philippe séguin refuse de
voter le budget du maire et abandonnent
leurs délégations
il y un an le capitaine du pétrolier
erika envoyait un premier message des
autorités maritimes avant de faire
naufrage
quelques heures plus tard à nos envoyés
spéciaux en inde le capitaine reconnaît
ses erreurs
cinéma avec le nouveau film du japonais
kitano ali qui mon frère sorti mercredi
prochain alors c'est le premier bilan de
l'enquète de dépistage de l'esb et lancé
en juin dernier une enquête qui a porté
sur quinze mille animaux dont 32 ont été
révélés positifs à titre de précaution
tous les bovins accidenté soit 25000
parents seront retirés de la chaîne
alimentaire
l'explication jean bernard schmidt et
pascal quint c'est une annonce dont on
se serait bien passé dans ce petit
village des deux sèvres le 130e cas
français de vache folle depuis le début
de l'année il a été repéré la semaine
dernière le reste du troupeau a été
abattu aujourd'hui un nouveau cas qui
vient étrangement conforter les
résultats des quinze mille premiers
tests de dépistage menée en france
selon eux il y aurait plus de deux
bovins malades sur mille animaux testés
un chiffre qui confirme les prévisions
les plus pessimistes l'étude a été
réalisée dans l'ouest de la france
région réputée à haut risque autre
facteur aggravant
le dépistage a été effectués sur des
animaux trouvés morts ou abattus
d'urgence il confirme qu'il existe trois
années noires pour les bêtes
les bovins nés en 93 94 95 sont les plus
touchées avec respectivement 40 72 et 47
cas pourtant pour les autorités
sanitaires pas question de tirer des
conclusions hâtives
la seule décision concrète concerne les
animaux accidenté
que eh bien ces animaux dans un premier
temps fasse l'objet d'un test
systématique rapide avant d'être abattu
et nous souhaitons maintenant que ces
animaux soient traités comme les animaux
malades c'est aldi qui reste sur les
exploitations soit euthanasié sur les
exploitations est une entreprise dans la
chaîne alimentaire
car les animaux qui se blesse tout seul
son plus faible et donc éventuellement
malades et ce ne sont pas les seuls à
être rentrés la buse ivement dans la
chaîne alimentaire
l'étude met l'accent sur un probable
défaut du système classique de
surveillance qui aurait laissé passer
trop de bêtes contaminées
les scientifiques attendent désormais
pour se prononcer la poursuite du
programme jusqu'à 40 minutes est le
dépistage devrait être terminée au
printemps prochain et les éleveurs
poursuivre leurs manifestations pour
réclamer de nouvelles aides de l'état ce
fut le cas ce matin sur le marché aux
bestiaux de rabastens de bigorre dans
les hautes pyrénées puis cet après midi
200 agriculteurs ont entrepris de
contrôler les marchandises d'un entrepôt
frigorifique de steenvoorde près de la
frontière belge
plusieurs palettes de viande
d'importation avait des dates limites de
consommation dépassées et parfois de
plus de deux ans ces agriculteurs
protestent contre ces viandes importées
qui font dit il distille chuter les
cours des prix en france
en ille et vilaine à l'ail et près de
rennes olivier piou gabriel camilla sont
allés interroger des éleveurs après l
annonce de ce premier bilan des tests
révélant ses encéphalopathie spongiforme
bovine ses vaches pascal hervé ne leur
donnent d'eux qu'ils ont tant que de
l'aliment naturel et de l'herbe
il n'est donc pas inquiet d'éventuels
cas de sb dans son cheptel et pas
davantage surpris des premiers résultats
de la campagne de tests
moi je pense que c'est normal qu'on en
trouve puisqu'on cherche a effectivement
à elle trouvé les tests et donc c'est
normal qu'on trouve des animaux positif
bon c'est vrai que nous ce qu'on demande
toute façon est ce qu'on attend c'est
surtout que ces résultats des dépistages
se fasse sur l'ensemble des animaux qui
passe aujourd'hui dans la chaîne
alimentaire c'est absolument
indispensable
mais pour ce militant de la
confédération paysanne les tests
agissent aussi comme un révélateur de
dérives qui se serait produite après
l'interdiction des farines pour bovins
des enquêtes judiciaires sont en cours
mais elle semble aujourd'hui au point
mort
apparemment il ya certains juges ou
certains procureurs n'ont pas les
documents qui leur sont nécessaires pour
mener à bien les enquêtes crois que
c'est important de bien déterminer où ou
est-ce que les farines comment excuser
elles ont été importés qui les a un
portrait et qui couvre les gens en fait
qui ont fait du trafic de farines
animales
du côté de la fnsea dont les dirigeants
régionaux étaient réunis aujourd'hui à
rennes on redoute surtout les
conséquences de cette campagne de tests
pour l'image de la filière en
particulier en bretagne il est est
aujourd'hui en effet surtout j'irai dans
l'ouest de la france
faut pas non plus qu'on mette à mal à
mal l'image aussi de l'élevage de hugh
grant west niveau national nous ne
souhaitait que les tests faits sur en
cent du territoire national ce qui va
sans doute être généralisé dans les
temps qui viennent
mais pour l'instant on risque nous de
recevoir encore une image très négative
sur une même page de la durante ouest
français du coup la fnsea annonce une
grande campagne en faveur de la
traçabilité du boeuf confédération fnsea
tous les éleveurs partage en tout cas la
même inquiétude que ces résultats
prévisibles pourtant ne relance dans
l'opinion
la psychose de la vache folle bon ou
mauvais accord un verre à moitié plein
ou à moitié vide c'est selon les points
de vue un résultat convenable décevant
pour le sommet de l'union européenne de
nice les 15 étant donné naissance à un
nouveau traité européen prévoyant un
élargissement vers les pays de l'est
cet avenir de l'union européenne a
nécessité des arrangements très délicat
pour que chaque pays membres soit
équitablement représentées à la
commission de bruxelles et au parlement
de strasbourg commentaires jean-marc qui
n'osent pas de remède de cheval pour
doter l'europe d'aujourd'hui à cases
comme celle de demain à 27
d'institutions moins rigide le traité de
nice aura dû prescrire des doses
homéopathiques commission européenne
pour alléger l'organe exécutif
plus qu'un seul commissaire par pays
quinze aujourd'hui 27 demain les seins
plus grands européens ont accepté de
renoncer à leur deuxième représentant au
conseil des ministres en revanche
rééquilibrage au profit des grands états
pour réduire la sur représentation des
pays peu peuplé dans l'europe de demain
allemagne france italie et royaume-uni
voit le nombre de leurs voix passé de 10
à 29
l'espagne on aura 27 comme demain la
pologne
lens pour les décisions qui désormais ne
seront plus prises à l'unanimité mais à
la majorité qualifiée les grands pays
pourront demander qu'elle corresponde au
moins à 62 % de la population totale de
l'europe pas de précipitation dans les
domaines qu'ils considèrent comme
sensibles les grands pays ont réussi à
se préserver un droit de veto la grande
bretagne en matière sociale et fiscale
la france au nom de l'exception
culturelle l'allemagne sur le contrôle
de son immigration au parlement d'une
europe à 27 le nombre de députés sera
plafonnée à 728 avec 80 millions
d'habitants l'allemagne conserve ses 99
députés
mais la france population oblige en perd
avec désormais 72 parlementaire
seulement les petits pays parfois à
l'origine de l'aventuré européenne comme
la belgique quitte nice avec le
sentiment d'avoir été bousculé le seul
concert de louanges viendra des 13 pays
candidats qui de la pologne la lettonie
où tu applaudis le difficile compromis
dennis l'accord niçois s'est donc fait à
l'arraché ce n'est que peu après 4h du
matin que jacques chirac et lionel
jospin ont pu donner leurs analyses
reflétant une cohabitation presque
parfaite récit de ces dernières heures
niçoise pour les européens avec alban
nicosie didier rancoeur au moment de
quitter nice à 5 heures du matin passée
jacques chirac et lionel jospin offre
ostensiblement l'image d'un exécutif
unis est soulagée par l'accord signé
soulagé car la nuit fut agité et
interminable nice restera comme le
sommet le plus long de l'histoire de la
construction européenne
il faut dire qu'on est passé tout près
d'un échec à 22h45 hier le portugal et
la belgique mène la fronde des petits
pays qui refusent de valider la nouvelle
répartition des voix proposée par la
france
le blocage est patent on négocie même
sur la terrasse le moment est difficile
dira plus tard le chef de l'état il
faudra que les méthodes de travail
changent c'est pas normal
de terminer à chaque heure du matin
finalement au bout de la nuit les
délégations réapparaissent avec à la
main le document tant attendu pour
revient alors de loin la présidence
française ne cherche même pas à cacher
son soulagement
j'entends parfois certains dirar n'a pas
suffisamment d'ambition n'y a qu'à faire
ceux ci n'y a qu'à faire cela mais faire
l'europe c'est naturellement obtenir un
certain nombre de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement en liaison avec la
commission des progrès mais c'est aussi
faire ratifier ces projets par les
populations
si vous mesurez ce que ray et été un
échec
à ce moment vous pouvez aussi apprécier
l'importance de ce qui vient d'être
décidé
même si on peut les uns et des autres se
fixe et naturellement des objectifs plus
ambitieux une volonté contré par exemple
par les britanniques qui n'ont fait
aucune concession sur la politique
sociale
ce fut donc un sommet laborieux dans
tous les sens du terme avec un traité
que le chef de l'état ira dès demain
défendre devant le parlement européen de
strasbourg
les pays candidats à l'entrée dans
l'union sont réjouies notamment la
hongrie la pologne mais en france les
réactions politiques
hormis cette du rpr et du parti
socialiste souligne surtout un manque
d'ambition pour les verts c'est un
sommet de l'inutile et pour jean marie
le pen celui de la capitulation
française reportage thomas dandois ce
sommet de nice devait être le point
d'orgue yeux de la présidence française
de l'union européenne
mais cet accord signé à la dernière
minute est loin de faire l'unanimité
le parti socialiste et le rpr sont bien
seuls aujourd'hui pour saluer le bon
travail des élèves chirac et jospin
quoique on est projeté vers l'avenir il
y avait un risque de blocage vous savez
le gouvernement avait dit le chef de
l'état aussi plutôt pas d'accord du tout
qu'un mauvais accord
il y à un accord aujourd'hui c'est parce
que cet accord est bon même s'il ne
résout pas toutes les questions il
permet d'avancer
je dirais que le sommet de nice est un
succès pour la présidence française n'en
déplaise à ceux qui prédisaient un échec
et je crois que tous les acteurs doivent
en être remercié le président de la
république en premier lieu mais aussi le
premier ministre et les ministres qui
ont été directement concernés en
revanche pour les autres
à droite comme à gauche les critiques
fusent le bilan est jugé un futur et
l'asi part par manque de vision par
manque d'ambition par manque de souffle
parce qu'on n'a pas posé les bonnes
questions
ce sommet se termine sur un compromis
riquiqui l'accord se fait sur les
concessions que chacun a pu faire je
crois qu'on aurait été beaucoup plus
fort et qu'on aurait on en serait sortie
avec une ambition plus grande
s'il s'était agit au contraire de mettre
en commun des atouts et de mettre en
commun des objectifs pour les de trouver
les moyens de les réaliser en sol
présidence française ou pas chacun se
détermine surtout par rapport à sa
propre vision de leur et il n'y a pas
plus de consensus dans la classe
politique
c'est vers l'europe et ses représentants
au parlement de strasbourg qu'une partie
du peuple tzigane se tourne depuis
plusieurs semaines des digues anne venue
de hongrie qui se sont réfugiés à
strasbourg il s'estime persécuté et
victime de discrimination aux attentes
de la france
un asile politique et de l'europe une
reconnaissance de leurs droits
voyez le reportage d'agnès garder diane
richard allez debout là dedans
réveillez vous les enfants leur nuit
n'ont jamais été aussi sereine leur
sommeil aussi lourd faut dire qu'ils
reviennent de loin de hongrie un pays où
dit il il ne fait pas bon être dit
gagnent ils ont brûlé nos maisons il
nous agresser physiquement c'est pour ça
qu'on est parti parce que tous les jours
on est humilié pas le droit d'entrer
dans les magasins c'est comme l'école
elle est interdite pour nos enfants et
les voiles après la fuite dans cette
maison où ils se sentent en sécurité
un ancien bâtiment municipal prêté par
la ville de strasbourg
voilà quatre mois qu'ils sont à l'abri
arrivé sans bagage ni papier il demande
l'asile politique au nom des
persécutions subies dans leur pays
on avait affaire au tout début des gens
qui était paniqué et donc qu'ils étaient
terrorisés la new et la nuit on était
présent au tout début et les enfants
avait mal au ventre et les parents
avaient peur et donc cette panique s'est
dissipée grâce
un autre modèle se présente leur vie est
elle menacée là d'où ils viennent
c'est à cette question que doit répondre
l'offre à l'office français des réfugiés
si oui l'asile leur sera accordée en
attendant les journées s'étirent
interminable oui c'est vrai on n'a pas
d'argent on n'a pas de travail mais au
moins ici on est en paix ce jour là au
milieu d'une session parlementaire une
poignée de députés européens sont venus
saluer les 70 galles et surtout prêcher
la bonne parole
nous n'avons pas été élus pour fabriquer
l'europe des marchés et que pour parler
de l'euro nous sommes là aussi pour dire
attention aujourd'hui danger il ya des
familles qui ont leur maison était un
brûlé des familles qui ont été mis à la
porte de chez eux quand on est obligé de
fuir qui arrivent chez nous et ne pourra
pas aujourd'hui les traités comme des
moins que rien la hongrie veut adhérer à
l'union européenne elle s'y est engagée
avec zèle mais le cas de ces roms qui
ont préféré l'exil rappelle que ce pays
n'a toujours pas réglé le problème de
ces minorités nouvelle réunion sur
l'avenir des régimes de retraites
complémentaires entre syndicats et
patronat il est prévu que la négociation
s'achève le 21 décembre prochain pour
sauvegarder les actuels régimes de
retraite le medef comme la cfdt ont fait
des propositions qui ont parfois heurter
les autres partenaires
explications avec nathalie moisi et
vincent ferreira françoise les très bien
sa place à des plus jeunes
elle vend des vêtements depuis tellement
longtemps ces enfants sont grands et
elle a cotisé plus de 160 trimestres
comme le veut la loi
pourtant impossible aujourd'hui pour
elle de prendre sa retraite j'ai
commencé à travailler à 17 ans et malgré
mes enfants j'écoute toujours travaillé
donc je suis arrivé à 55 ans avec un
nombre de trimestres suffisant pour
prendre ma retraite mais la loi
actuellement ne m'autorise pas à la
prendre à un taux correct
en france tout salarié doit cotiser
pendant 40 ans pour avoir une retraite
pleine et jusqu'à 60 ans comme notre
vendeuse trois cent mille personnes
auraient suffisamment cotisé cette année
pour s'arrêter avant la cdt propose de
leur donner une retraite à taux plein ce
salarié lorsqu'il les retraités a une
espérance de vie plus faible que la
moyenne
donc ce n'est que normal ce n'est que
justice car salariés leurs six data ses
40 années de cotisation s'ils le
désirent s'y notamment il est fatigué
ils puissent partir en retraite
fini alors l'âge légal de la retraite à
60 ans
chiche dit le patronat qui propose
d'allonger la durée de cotisation
notamment pour tous ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tard dans tous les
pays de l'europe sans exception c'est
fin c'est pas faire ses fins il n'ya
plus que la france qui ne se soit pas
réformé de ce point de vue là mais dans
un pays comme la suède est un pays
ferait sociale eh bien on parle
maintenant de 67 ans donc nous n'en
sommes pas là nous nous disons 65
peut-être en 2023 mais pour force
ouvrière où la cgt la retraite à 60 ans
doit être préservé d'autant
qu'aujourd'hui six salariés sur dix nous
quitter l'entreprise avant 60 ans
parfois volontairement souvent
contraints et forcés
un spectacle politique inédit au conseil
de paris une bonne vingtaine d'adjoint
au maire devenu fidèle de philippe
seguin ont rendu leur délégation à jean
tiberi celui-ci refusé de reporter
l'examen du projet de budget pour 2010
au lendemain des élections municipales
pour jean tiberi c'est un putsch et pour
les socialistes c'est désolant
reportage laurent estime philippe
deslandes à la mairie de paris
le matin on déballe ses amertumes en
séance l'après midi on remballe ses
affaires dans des cartons les élus
séguiniste de l'hôtel de ville ont
décidé de mener la vie dure à jean
tiberi alors une poignée d'adjoint a
rendu son tablier
je crois que c'est un beau coup
et concrètement qu'est ce que j'allais
faire ou on va repasser des v nations je
pas une difficulté
la ville continuera à tourner pour une
fois et malgré cette crise
un seul homme s'est permis ce matin de
voler la vedette à jean tiberi c'est
michel roussin mises en examen dans la
sphère des marchés publics d'île de
france
l'élu chiraquien est alors très entouré
à droite comme à gauche
pendant ce temps les séguiniste demande
qu'on reporte le vote du budget histoire
d'empêcher le maire d'utiliser la baisse
des impôts comme argument électoral
à l'heure de la pause la droite se
déchire en public c'est la majorité qui
ne reconnaît plus aujourd'hui l'autorité
du maire car dissémine naturellement en
position de candidat et il essaye
d'utiliser le conseil de paris comme une
tribune électorale je ne comprends pas
que d'un coup que hier en réalité via
l'app les choses par leur nom
une espèce d'opérations politiques venus
d'ailleurs et pour ce qui est de lier
jean tiberi a sa petite idée
c'est une manoeuvre politicienne qui
résulte un ordre
écoutez moi bien d'un ordre donné par
quelqu'un de l'extérieur mais ce séguin
qui n'est pas élu parisien et ils
obéissent au doigt et à l'oeil
tout ça est ce assez marrant alors une
fois encore les socialistes en campagne
pour décrocher la capitale n'ont plus
qu'à compter les points cette droite
obsédé par les enjeux de pouvoir par la
tactique de complaire politicienne est
en train de faire beaucoup de mal à
paris le dernier budget tiberi sera mis
au vote demain matin il ya de fortes
chances qu'il soit rejeté
et quel qu'il soit le nouveau maire de
paris élue en mars aura toutes les
peines du monde à boucler son budget
avant le 15 avril comme le veut la loi à
lyon l'un des candidats potentiels à la
succession de raymond barre le député
henry chabert comparaissait cet
après-midi devant le tribunal
correctionnel aux côtés de neuf autres
prévenus pour recel d'abus de biens
sociaux
compte rendu d'audience didier guyot et
thierry monnet il ya encore un an
richard baer était donné comme le favori
des lyonnais qui caracolait dans les
sondages le fauteuil de nerfs lui
semblait tout destinée aujourd'hui
quatre mois avant les municipales
le voici jugé pour recel d'abus de biens
sociaux le candidat chabert ne peut pas
faire campagne au coeur de ses ennuis
judiciaires sa résidence secondaire dans
la drôme une maison rénovée pour 400
mille francs en 1993 par la société
billon des travaux sous facturés selon
certains experts qui estiment le vrai
montant à quelque un million cent onze
mille francs puis de 700 mille francs de
différence
j'estime que tous les hommes politiques
doivent d'ailleurs passés par ce même
crime je regrette d'ailleurs que
certains donc certaine façon il passe
pas mais peu importe donc c'est logique
qu'on y passe je regrette en revanche je
déplore que le calendrier
en revanche judiciaires viennent se
superposer un peu trop près du
calendrier électoral
au départ de la sphère trois lettres
anonymes un combat politique dire henry
chabert des lettres qui parlait des
travaux de sa maison mais aussi de
l'association forum européen qu'il
présidait de généreux donateurs dans la
société billon les dettes a fonctionné
or à l'époque henry chabert était
adjoint à l'urbanisme pour la justice
cette association était un lieu d'
influence entre amis entrepreneurs
une accusation que réfute la défense au
départ on pense qu'il ya une véritable
machine à faire de l'argent public au
détriment donc du contribuable
c'est à partir de là que l'on enquête et
c'est dans cette optique la clau ok on
se rend compte après des mois donc après
des procès verbaux par dizaines mais par
centaines qu'ils n'y a jamais rien
ni et qu'il n'y avait rien à chercher de
ce côté là c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu le héros de la fable
mais dans le dossier quelques
interrogations tout de même sur la
générosité des entrepreneurs était ce
vraiment amitié ou pour d'éventuels
comptes en partie les ce matin dans
cette même ville de lyon le maire
monsieur raymond barre avait à ses côtés
le ministre jack lang pour inaugurer la
nouvelle école normale supérieure de
lettres et sciences humaines
un chantier qui était jugé pharaonique
par une centaine d'étudiants qui ont
protesté contre les dysfonctionnements
cette école à l'occasion de son
inauguration aux états unis à washington
les neuf juges de la cour suprême
fédérale ont entendu les avocats des
démocrates et des républicains à propos
du décompte des voix en floride
l'enjeu est majeur selon le décompte
soit poursuivie ou définitivement arrêté
autour du bâtiment de la cour suprême la
tension était donc très perceptible
trente quatre jours après les élections
correspondance etienne leenhardt avec
aaron diamant d'une certaine manière la
patience des américains et la confiance
qu'ils manifestent dans leurs
institutions sont assez admirable
voilà trente quatre jours qu'ils
attendent de savoir qui les dirigera
pour quatre ans et ce matin pendant
cette audience cruciale il continué de
s'époumoner ce qui est en jeu est claire
le droit de chaque électeur à voir son
vote prises en compte
mais selon que l'on est supporter de
george bush ou d'al gore on ne voit pas
forcément les choses de la même façon
même les voltigeurs pour moi chaque vote
compte vote c'est un vote
et c'est au peuple dans ces démocraties
de choisir son président les bulletins
litigieux ne sont pas cités dans
certains états alors pourquoi les
comptes et en floride
je veux bien qu'on coule tous les votes
le fronton les oranje avec les oranje
pas les oranje avec les pommes même au
sein de la cour suprême les neuf sages
sont très divisés nommés à vie par des
présidents en exercice ils ont forcément
une étiquette politique plus ou moins
républicains plus ou moins démocrate
qu'en théorie toutefois ils ne doivent
pas affiches mais dans la matière cette
saga électorale est devenu si sensible
que si leur décision est prise à une
courte majorité ils seront
inévitablement accusé d' esprit partisan
une nouvelle fois on a fait preuve de
transparence en rendant public
l'enregistrement sonore des débats avec
à la clé un verdict sans appel qui
pourrait être rendu dès ce soir
quel que soit de la majorité par
laquelle sera prise cette décision si la
cour suprême décide que ce décompte
manuel doit reprendre en floride eh bien
on entre dans une nouvelle phase
d'incertitudes en revanche si elle
décide que le dépouillement manuel ne
peut reprendre et bien un george bush le
républicain aura définitivement sans
doute pour se gagner à santiago du chili
la cour d'appel vient d'annuler
l'inculpation et l'assignation à
résidence du général pinochet et des
avions ainsi deux juges d'instruction
juan guzman qui avait estimé que
l'ancien dictateur était bien le
commanditaire d'enlèvement et
d'exécutions sommaires perpétrées en
1973 nelson mandela à paris l'ancien
président sud africain a reçu un accueil
enthousiaste la promotion de l'ena qui
porte son nom
mais auparavant monsieur mandela avait
été reçu par jacques chirac et lionel
jospin on le voit ici arrivée à matignon
il était venu leur demander de son
summer soutien pour le programme de
reconstruction du burundi 3 milliards de
francs c'est le coup provisoire de la
catastrophe de l'erika le chiffre a été
donné un an après le naufrage du
pétrolier c'était le 12 décembre 99 mais
dès le 11 décembre le capitaine de l'
erika l'indien karun matour adressé un
message aux autorités maritimes et à son
armateur messages contradictoires ces
erreurs le capitaine les reconnaît pour
la première fois dans un entretien qu'il
vient d'accorder à patrick fandio et
frédéric faure chez lui à udaipur c'est
non loin de délits
autour du nouveau né presque toute la
famille réunie
celle de carreaux de matour nouveau papa
ex capitaine de l'erika ce soir là on
fait la kutxa une bénédiction un goût
pour les six jours de son second enfant
je suis vraiment vraiment très heureux
d'avoir une fille maintenant on a une
belle complète ses proches le savent
c'est sans doute la meilleure chose qui
lui soit arrivée cette année depuis son
retour au pays en février un retour à
auteuil pour dans l'état du rajasthan au
nord de l'inde
on y vient en général pourra tenir et le
faste des palais des dernier maharadja
ou encore goûter aux charmes de l'inde
traditionnelles loin très loin de
l'erika le capitaine s'est réfugié ici
pour tout oublier le naufrage le juge la
prison ses cauchemars
un an après le traumatisme est passé à
notre demande
caron de matour s'est replongé dans ses
souvenirs vous nous expliquer par
exemple pourquoi il avait annulé son
message de détresse
il plaide l'erreur je n'ai pas réalisé
que la structure du bateau était si
faible je pensais qu'elle était
suffisamment résistante pour arriver
jusqu'au port mais pas penser qu'il y
avait un trou dans la coque à ce moment
là à ce moment là non je n'ai pas
réalisé que c'était si grave erreur
d'appréciation ou mensonge délibéré aux
autorités maritimes
dans ce telex adressé à 14h34 au cross
etel le capitaine se veut rassurant
j'examine encore la situation
je ne veux pas d'assistance immédiate
mais dont la foulée c'est un tout autre
message qu'il envoie à 14h42 à peine 8
minutes plus tard cette fois à ses
employeurs italien panne chip
je vois du fioul qui s'échappe dans la
mer il y a plusieurs fissures sur le
pont principal
les informations qui confirment
aujourd'hui vous avez vu à 14h34
du fioul s'échapper de l'erika oui
effectivement j'ai vu un filet de
pétrole mais quand le bateau s'est
redressée le pétrole avait disparu vous
savez quand on est près des côtes
on doit prévenir les autorités mais là
on était trop loin des côtes françaises
à ce moment là donc évidemment je n'ai
pas informé les autorités de khost le
capitaine n'a pas voulu que l'erika ce
faste au p our remorqué au large
il n'a pas voulu ou n'a pas osé prendre
cette décision qui aurait coûté cher à
son armateur il n'a pas murray les
autorités que vers 21h sept heures ont
été perdus 7 heures pendant lesquelles
il fait route vers les côtes avec sa
cargaison en fuite
ce qui lui vaut sa mise en examen pour
pollution marine
au chômage depuis un an karun mathur ne
se sont pas responsables s'ils
naviguaient sur un vieux pétrolier musée
c'est parce que dit-il
en tant qu'officier indien on n'a pas
toujours le choix vous savez chaque
armateurs s'arrange pour que le bateau
naviguer le plus longtemps possible
les équipages des pays riches ne veulent
pas naviguer sur des vieux bateaux alors
ils viennent les chercher ici en inde
si un jour il y avait un procès en
france
il a déjà prévenu il ne se déplacera pas
il préfère attendre ici des jours
meilleurs
voilà puis je signale un numéro spécial
de l'oiseau magazine hors série marée
noire un an après publié par la ligue
pour la protection des oiseaux qui
raconte le travail des bénévoles pour
sauver des milliers d'oiseaux victimes
de l'erika un très grave accident
d'autobus à morne à l'eau c'est non loin
de pointe-à-pitre en guadeloupe
l'autobus été heurté par un poids lourd
il ya neuf morts dont trois enfants
depuis 19 blessés forte émotion sur
place le sujet spa et violente mais
fruits mais sa grande émotion aux
familles des victimes
ouverture ce matin devant le tribunal
correctionnel de bordeaux du procès
intenté aux sociétés exploitant les
silos de blaye en gironde le 20 août 97
ces silos avait explosé faisant 11 morts
c'est la sécurité de ces installations
qui est maintenant mise en cause
commentaires de roter kutcher une fois
l'incendié éteint les feux les disperser
voilà ce qu'il restait du silo à
céréales
onze personnes sont mortes sous les
décombres c'était il ya trois ans et
demi aujourd'hui avec le procès on se
pose la question des responsabilités et
tout d'abord l'emplacement des bureaux
au pied du silo
autrement dit beaucoup trop près maman
plaisanter avec les collègues du bureau
genre il ya eu l'accident les indiens un
jour on prendra sur la gueule elle
plaisanté mais elle plaisanté quand même
elle le disait autre débat d'ordre
technique celui là il faut savoir que
lorsqu'elle est en suspension
la poussière des silos peut être aussi
explosive que le butane ou le kérosène
une seule étincelle et voilà ce qui se
produit
d'où cette interrogation l'explosion est
elle due ou pas à un ventilateur
défaillant autrement dit les dirigeants
ont-ils été négligent si j'avais vu des
négligences de réelles négligence de la
part de la direction locale
j'aurais depuis bien longtemps demandé à
roger capella de quitter la société
il sera d'autant plus difficile de
savoir la raison précise de l'explosion
que le ventilateur le moteur la réserve
à poussière tout a été détruit
le tribunal a une semaine pour juger à
bassens en gironde ce matin des
militants de greenpeace ont empêché le
déchargement d'une cargaison de soja
présumé transgénique
deux des cales de ce céréalier ont
cependant été vidés car documents à
l'appui le soja n'étaient pas
génétiquement modifiés le céréalier
contenait quand même dix mille tonnes de
soja ogm réservé à l'alimentation
animale l'entreprise importatrice serait
engagé c'est ce que dira inpi sonne plus
utiliser ce type de soja dans son usine
de bordeaux pour avoir frappé un
directeur d'école
un père de famille a été condamné à dix
mois de prison ferme par un tribunal
correctionnel de colmar
cet homme dont le casier judiciaire par
ailleurs comporte déjà plusieurs
condamnations pour violences avaient
frappé vendredi dernier le directeur de
l'école où son fils venait d'être
réprimandés et puis en italie le
champion cycliste marco pantani vient
d'être condamné à trois mois de prison
avec sursis pour fraude sportive quand
la nation par tribunal de forli dans le
nord de l'italie du sport du football
nouveau changement à la tête de la
première division non payante était
battu hier après midi à marseille
bordeaux hier soir en a profité grâce à
sa victoire 2 1 sur saint-etienne grâce
notamment à l'opportunisme ça c'est le
premier but de saint-etienne
l'opportuniste de l'avant centre
bordelais pauleta
nantes four à son match en retard
mercredi à bastia
voilà le but peu avant la fin de l'année
on décerne des prix celui du club de
football du siècle et aller au real de
madrid mais pour le joueur du siècle il
y a eu un peu embrouillé d'abord sur
internet maradona a été couronnée malgré
ses frasques
la fédération internationale ensuite un
peu corrigé cela en attribuant un autre
prix appelé et puis le joueur de l'année
c'est zidane commenté christelle
bertrand le football est à son tour
touchée par le syndrome à la mode
l'élection compliqué la fédération
internationale a voulu élire le joueur
du siècle le roi pelé a d'abord fait
l'unanimité le brésilien vainqueur de
trois coupes du monde auteur de 1281
buts a marqué l'histoire du football
en 1958 alors qu'il n'a pas dix huit ans
exxon arantes do nascimento inscrit deux
buts en finale contre la suède
il devient le nouveau héros du brésil
les voilà ces images ont plus de 40 ans
la fifa a voulu utiliser les moyens de
communication d'aujourd'hui
des élections ont aussi eu lieu sur
internet peu les inconnus des jeunes
internautes n'a pas gagné
il y avait une différence énorme contre
les réseaux hta d'internet et pas
l'autre voir que nous avions choisi ces
deux départs là le magazine doit fifa il
y avait une différence extraordinaire
maradona joueur du siècle sur internet
fiers d'apprendre la nouvelle l'argentin
s'est déclaré vainqueur mettant dans
l'embarras les instances internationales
obligé de décerner un deuxième trophée
au vainqueur de la coupe du monde 86
comparé à pelé il n'a marqué que 2 158
buts mais ses exploits sont plus récents
oublier les nombreuses cures de
désintoxication de maradona l'internaute
est indulgent ce soir la fifa consacre
aussi le real madrid
coop a dit stefano ou encore anelka ont
porté les célèbres couleurs du club du
siec qui lui a fait l'unanimité
voile the way ce en raison de mauvaises
conditions météo le prologue de la
course à la voile autour du monde en
équipage a été annulée à monaco ce
prologue devait avoir lieu vendredi et
samedi prochain du cinéma mercredi sur
les écrans vous pourrez apprécier le
nouveau film du japonais kitano intitulé
aniki mon frère dans le monde du
gangstérisme urbain de los angeles
kitano donne sa version personnelle
présentation pascal des chiens frédéric
de large chemise claire costume sombre
takeshi kitano arbore dans la vie la
même élégance hors du temps la même
impassibilité énigmatique que les héros
de ces films flic solitaire voyous
vengeurs ils sont comme absent à eux
mêmes samurai désespéré qui s'accrochent
à leur cause à leur code d'honneur comme
un naufragé à une bouée de sauvetage m'a
donné l'ordre que de pâtes une balle à
la tête
à personne et dérange
et d'autre part il doute de ma loyauté
du mois
à quoi
geoffrey avec aniki mon frère il nous
entraîne sur les traces d'un yakuza un
mafieux japonais contraints à l'exil aux
états unis il y affrontera une nouvelle
mafia mais il parlera à la même langue
celle des armes
les personnages sont condamnés à une
sorte de fatalité il ya tout ça c'est
quelqu'un qui a sans arrêt besoin d'un
ennemi pour vivre sa vie c'est la gueule
on va tous mourir si je dois mourir je
mourrai avec ce film le réalisateur
japonais fait plus que changer de décor
il exporte aux etats unis une autre
façon d'aborder la violence au cinéma
comme pour dire aux puissants
d'hollywood vos dollars vos effets
spéciaux ne m'impressionnent guerre
vous souvenez du nombre d'accidents de
voiture mon assistant america m'a dit il
faut que la voiture partance zigzags de
tous nous je suis répondu la violence
doit être froide sobre de notre honneur
impossible intermédiaire entre l'orient
et l'occident entre le passé et l'avenir
kitano continue de tracer son chemin un
chemin pavé d'une tendresse pour ses
semblables aussi profonde qui est
profond son désespoir
aniki mon frère de kitano c'est mercredi
sur les écrans en france nous avions la
fin de cette émission je rappelle deux
activités que nous avons développées
tout d'abord le premier bilan d'une
enquête de dépistage de
l'encéphalopathie spongiforme bovine es
b pour les catégories étudiées on a
relevé un taux de deux bêtes malades
pour mille
et puis il ya un an le capitaine du
pétrolier erika envoyé un premier
message aux autorités maritimes avant de
faire naufrage
quelques heures plus tard le 12 décembre
99 à nos envoyés spéciaux
il a reconnu ses erreurs mais ne veut
plus revenir en france pour un éventuel
procès
la météo c'est dans quelques instants
avec nathalie rihouet 23h10 le magazine
mots croisés présentée par arlette
chabot et alain duhamel sur thème de la
délinquance des mineurs des jeunes
victimes de la violence sur le plateau
des parents des preuves des magistrats
et des policiers
le dernier journal de la rédaction c'est
à 00h45 avec jean claude renault demain
c'est en cinq ans dans les 4 vérités
gérard morin recevra francis teitgen qui
le bâtonnier de l'ordre des avocats de
paris à propos de la grève générale des
avocats de 20 à 13 heures vous
retrouverez gérard holtz à demain 21
bonsoir merci